forever and a day the title of the first
film about the scorpions
the band attended the world premiere in
Berlin in early February although they
can look back on a 50-year long career
the film is special for them too
it's a wholly new experience for us
seeing the band on a big screen together
with an audience and being here during
the Berlin ala Film Festival that's a
special moment for us a camera crew
followed the scorpions around for three
years the result is a 100 minute epic on
the most commercially successful German
rock band ever with 100 million records
sold and countless world hits like still
loving you
along with spectacular live shows the
film shows some private moments as well
and it goes back to the beginning the
1960s and 70s and the first performances
leading up to their global success
he's a seen des the scenes from the
first years are especially interesting
who wants to hear that a band like us
can sell have a stadium now they assume
that no one wants to hear about it
filming started in 2011 during the
scorpions farewell tour the camera crew
accompanied the band on many appearances
including throughout the u.s. France and
Thailand in the end it was a challenge
splicing together all the footage like
phyla I wanted to tell the stories that
I found the most impressive but in the
end I mainly looked for personal and
entertaining moments the farewell tour
was planned as a goodbye to the world
stages but along the way the musicians
got so much positive feedback they
changed their tune and said goodbye to
the goodbye
the sliminess that instant life rewrote
the script a little because the film was
meant to show a career at its end with
the last concert but as is the case so
often in life when you want to leave
they won't let you push a head of DWS
culture department came up with the idea
for the first big musical documentary on
the scorpions seven years ago from the
start we had a big screen film in mind
it's always more exciting for the
filmmakers and the audience to have big
films to have big projects that are
ultimately fascinating and interesting
and of course reach a wide audience
dhana dhan paayo is probably completely
the post premiere party forever and a
day is also a dream come true for the
scorpions
it's a wonderful film and of course
we're happy about getting all this
positive feedback
the world premiere in Berlin a huge
success the film opens in German
theaters at the end of March and will
later be distributed internationally and
of course DW TV will also be
broadcasting forever and a day
ahead of their farewell tour the
Scorpions recorded their 17th studio
album sting in the tail shot to number
two in the German charts the first hit
single in our pop export scorpion
special is the good die young
your heart is beating
fight the crayon
No
see
you